welcome Jo koy yeah rich Watson our
society so I love this hi Jo
no you're just talking about how rich
loss was upset you know more okay yeah
the boss was upset that Bob Kelly liked
his friend Bob gets asked to host the
nasty show Josh's first response is why
didn't they ask me to host it's always
him it always goes back to him Neela
Voss says divorce is the most honest
version of a comedian because every
comedian would think that yeah like most
people would have the common grace not
to say it wash just doesn't have that
he's just got Asperger's no he's got it
comes out oh it's not daddy's [ __ ] he's
72 he's panicking about the last five
years of his career is that Chris yeah
Chris Chris come in come on in he's
going to get a coffee
Oh [ __ ] manager how do you know what
he's doing
because he's a fatty inside I know it
[Applause]
what's up man how were you trying to get
food just now or was Bob Jim and Sam
shirt we really should make sure it's
where we just put our faces all we
should make everybody wear it or you
don't get in that's right that's right
now is buy one knows we Bob Kelly
displacing his fatness on to you or
worry what's that your interface um I
mean I'm definitely hungry but I didn't
I didn't uh you were right how do you
feel now you wanted to be twink you just
called me fat in a weird roundabout way
What did he say Bob
sorry Chuck Joe's going with these with
Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe quois what I want to
look like and the career I want yeah
Joey especially did really well man
gratulations huh Thank You Man thank
he's wearing a gold Rolex is he I don't
look the watches and that wasn't
supposed to come out wait can I call you
Bobby is it my whole time I've known you
it's [ __ ] Robert your dick [ __ ] when
do I get to call you Bob call me Bobby
anytime you want you [ __ ] weirdo
thank you walk around a weirdo my name
is Joe I tell everyone to call me
[ __ ] Joey
[ __ ] face Robin yeah I'll be Robert
Bobby Bobby [ __ ] go by Bobby [ __ ]
over here Jerry Norton dick there's some
man so over here scientists face I look
like the after shot of a workout video
the joke I did already
[ __ ] [ __ ] I want to hear [ __ ]
so it's mine don't bring me I will
always remember [ __ ] dick did when I go
what you say goes on you if somebody's
calling you Robert cuz that's the name
you're Bill yes if somebody if I got
comedian is calling you Robert John you
to be like that's Bobby yeah no it is
it's on me say it on you well I know you
for many that's on me to tell a grown
man to cook
I got I get that [ __ ] name it's Bob
Bobby Rob Robert Robbie Bobby Bobby with
an IE Bobby with a why Bobby is Kelly is
it ey it's that [ __ ] name I hate
everybody says the same [ __ ] what should
I call you I don't give a [ __ ] call me
whatever you want you don't even have to
call me how's that just don't call me
late I'm not sure high five times in my
life he's acting like we [ __ ] I'll
know for a year did I call you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was you coming in too hot
jo koy so [ __ ] hot it is a fair
question though because I've known you
for 20 years not a family names do you
have for Jo Jo what else
jo okay now hold on Joey Joseph yeah
okay but you don't spoil with any right
Jo Jo yeah yes all right
I'm just saying Joe I'm not screaming I
just wanna be part of the [ __ ] game
it gets to call you Bob I'm on a goddamn
panel that is funny Bob that's baby
Robert you know it yeah there's no [ __ ]
you call me I want you to call me
[ __ ] Robert don't come up after the
show that was fun
here were you [ __ ] okay no idea how
[ __ ] read the back of Bobby's head is
right now the angle that I have the
camera yelling at me for well he's got
someone open for we're all gonna settle
this year yeah let's invite Joe to the
pizza party - okay you know we're all
gonna be friends we're on a panel
together on the show together we don't
like each other let's let's start fresh
we should start yeah that was a tense
beginning hey Joe how you doing I'm Bob
how are you there - I call you Robert
and that's why we're the [ __ ] pros
you [ __ ]